in this video i will show you how to use
kernels with this vm to perform
nonlinear classification
as you know svm creates a line or
hyperplane to separate data points into
classes the fact that the boundary
between classes is flat is a pro because
it makes svm easier to work with but it
is also a limitation because most
datasets in the real world cannot be
separated by hyperplane a workaround to
this limitation is to first apply a
nonlinear transformation to the data
points before applying svm
with this technique we can easily
achieve the desired effect of getting a
non-linear decision boundary without
changing how svm works internally
this is extremely easy to do in python
for example we load our training data
points and labels as usual but now when
we call svm's fit function we don't use
x but rather f x where f of x is a
non-linear transformation of x
geometrically this non-linear
transformation might look something like
this
svm will return a flat hyperplane
separating the two classes as usual but
in the original x space this corresponds
to a non-linear decision boundary
mission accomplished right should we
stop here and call it today
well not quite a first problem is that
we need to choose what this non-linear
transformation should be but as
everybody knows emily enthusiasts are
lazy people so the fewer choices we have
to make the happier we are
the second problem is that if we want a
sophisticated decision boundary we need
to increase the dimension of the output
of this transformation and this in turn
increases computational requirements
the so-called kernel trick was invented
to solve both of these problems in one
shot the idea is that the algorithm
behind this vm does not actually need to
know what each point is mapped to under
this nonlinear transformation
the only thing that it needs to know is
how each point compares to each other
data points after we apply the nonlinear
transformation
mathematically this corresponds to
taking the inner product between f of x
and f of x prime
and we call this quantity the kernel
function
for example the identity transformation
corresponds to the linear kernel given
by x transpose x prime
the linear kernel gives a flat decision
boundary which in this case is not good
enough to separate the data properly
a polynomial transformation like this
one corresponds to the polynomial kernel
note that the expression of the kernel
function is simple and easy to compute
even though the transformation itself is
complicated intuitively a polynomial
kernel takes into account the original
features of our data set just like that
linear kernel but on top of that it also
considers their interaction it takes a
single line of code to use this
polynomial kernel with this vm and as
expected this gives a curved decision
boundary
sometimes it is possible to give a
kernel function for which it is hard or
even impossible to find the
corresponding transformation a prime
example of this is the popular radial
basis function kernel not only is the
corresponding non-linear transformation
complicated it is actually infinite
dimensional so it is impossible to use
directly in a computer program but the
kernel expression is incredibly simple
and again with a single line of code you
can experiment with this kernel and you
can play with this parameter gamma to
make the boundary smooth or rough so in
summary the kernel trick is so
incredibly powerful that it feels like
using a cheat code in a video game not
only it is much easier to tweak and get
creative with kernels but we don't have
to worry about the dimension of the
output anymore thank you very much for
watching and see you next time